Kate Bravo Khan is here how is your
revoke on experience so far I've never
been to any con and so it was kind of
like do you want to meet your heroes
have you met some heroes yet today sure
have I met Kelly Dodd hair and makeup
but she's so cool and also she was on a
very large yacht earlier this summer and
then I met Cameron from southern charm
did we meet but no were just like social
media friends can we talk about this
season the makeout that's the way
smashton operates okay we've been
drinking I was like you know what no I
thought it was strange and I agree an
attack feels like the right word a mild
attack it was it was abrupt not invited
how far are we away from your walked off
no men don't follow me I don't know I
think I have a theory
you won't Kevin's the one who pushes you
to get so frustrated and then maybe you
come back and there's an ultimatum me or
Kevin I mean maybe I mean he certainly
frustrated me that's true
I'm not really an ultimatum girl unless
you ask the last three people I get it
but no you're very close all right I'll
take being very close Abby has left and
we're getting a deckhand who maybe we
know pleasantly surprised are you I'm
not ready for this
this deckhand is going to disrupt
Ashton's perfect little romance of a
deck crew which is I think necessary but
this deckhand this new deckhand is a
much harder worker than Abby and much
more experienced so I think it's an
upgrade for everyone for you I'm not
gonna allow her to rock the boat with
this happy family bleep in heaven Brandi
was quite the charter guests are we
gonna top her this season or is that
like the craziest thing we're gonna see
and there never has been anyone on a
yacht like Brandi I just feel privileged
that I got to experience it honestly she
was so so wild she was amazing she got
evacuated off a beach in a clear kayak
emergency medical kayak is not a thing
but it is now while wearing she's
wearing so many diamond bracelets
she's just who wakes up from alcohol
poisoning and asked for more alcohol is
the real question our sweet Brandi I
love Brandi she's a hoot how is Alexis
Bellino as a charter guest Orange County
housewife yes Alexis Bellino
she's off the Jesus juice and onto the
fermented grape juice there we go all
right thank you